life so far she spoke about it Thursday
at the National Press Club in Washington
DC for about an hour
good evening and welcome to the National
Press Club I'm Rick Dunham white house
correspondent for Businessweek magazine
and 2005 president of the National Press
Club I'd like to welcome Club members
and their guests in the audience today
along with those of you watching on
c-span or listening on National Public
Radio the video archive of today's
evening meal is provided by connect live
and is available to members only through
the National Press Club website wwr S
org Press Club members can also access
free transcripts of our luncheons at the
web site non-members may purchase
transcripts audio tapes or videotapes by
calling 888 343 1940 and if tonight's
event convinces you you should be a
member of the National Press Club being
get more information by calling six six
two seven five one one 202 area code if
any of you have questions for our
speaker please write them on the cards
provided at your tables and pass them up
to the head table and I will ask as many
as time permits before introducing our
head table I'd like to remind the
audience of some future speakers on
Wednesday April 20th secretary Jim
Nicholson of the US Department of
Veterans Affairs will speak on this
subject ensuring quality care for those
who need us most on Tuesday April 26th
we will have Senator Barack Obama of
Illinois and James Roosevelt the
grandson of President Roosevelt and a
former associate associate commissioner
of Social Security on Thursday April
28th Senator Chuck Hagel of Nebraska
will be our guest I'd now like to
introduce our head table guests and ask
them to stand briefly when their names
are called
please hold your applause until all head
table guests are introduced from your
right
caspere's athan of yomiuri shimbun the
National Press Club member Marilyn G wax
reporter for Cox newspapers the flagship
paper of which is the Atlanta
journal-constitution in the hometown
paper of our speaker and National Press
Club member Cecile Richards the
president of America votes and the
daughter of somebody I used to cover
when I worked for the Dallas Times
Herald and Richards Jane Podesta of
People magazine national
club member meshell is oomba executive
director of the Georgia campaign for
adolescent pregnancy prevention and a
guest of our speaker cathy bonk member
of the press club an executive director
of communications consortium Media
Center Kathy was responsible for
arranging tonight's dinner and thank you
very much Kathy Gloria Steinem American
legend the co-founder of New York
Magazine and MS magazine to my right
John Hughes of Bloomberg News the vice
chair of the National Press Club
speakers committee skipping over our
speaker live christine dorsey of the
National Wildlife Federation and the
speaker's committee member who arranged
today's luncheon Thank You Christine
Dennis Ryerson the editor of the
Indianapolis Star and a non resident
member we're very glad you could be here
with us tonight marine grothy of Gannett
News Service a member of the National
Press Club Board of Governors mark we
know of Dow Jones news service National
Press Club member and a member of my
Task Force on the arts Loraine Waller a
colleague of mine at Businessweek
magazine and a member of the National
Press Club speakers committee and
finally eleanor clift of newsweek
National Press Club member and another
journalistic legend
with us today is a truly remarkable
person Jane Fonda has accomplished in so
many ways she's an award-winning actress
she's a political activist
she's an admired philanthropist she
revolutionized the fitness industry and
she's certainly still in pretty good
shape she's been married to some pretty
famous men and she grew up in the
limelight of Hollywood loved by some and
as she would be the first to admit
loathe by others she probably means very
different things to different people
depending on your political persuasion
and on which decade you experienced Jean
Jane Fonda for the first time it was at
barefoot in the park or Barbarella
was it Vietnam was it the Academy Awards
she won or today as author of the number
one bestseller on the New York Times
bestseller list for my life so far
or was it those workout videos
let me ask how many of you owned a Jane
Fonda workout video that's pretty good
I'm told they're worth a pretty penny on
eBay these days but seriously Jane Fonda
is here today to talk about her life so
far which happens to be the subject of
the new memoir born in New York City
Jane Seymour Fonda grew up in Hollywood
with actor Henry Fonda as a father and
Francis Seymour Brokaw's a mother she
lived a life most of us would think we
would envy although as she has written
there was a dark side to the Hollywood
tale she took up the family business and
became an actress among her many notable
roles she won an Academy Award for her
1971 portrayal of Bree Daniel include
and then another for her role as Sally
Hyde in 1978 s coming home as she was if
I may be editorial Martha is acting
opposite her father in on Golden Pond a
fictional account of an estranged father
and daughter that is quite close to
reality and of course to millions of
young men and formerly young men she was
at always will be Barbarella although to
date myself as a once innocent
ten-year-old to me she will always be
kept blue yeah
in the 1960s many of us recall her
outspoken opposition to the Vietnam War
and 1970s I mean when she very publicly
protested the war from North Vietnam she
was dubbed Hanoi Jane and earned a
lifetime of contempt from some veterans
although many many veterans have been
her friends for many years - despite
what some of them would have wished Jane
Fonda's activism didn't diminish her
shining star in Hollywood and she can
boast fifty movies among her cadre of
film projects today she lives in Atlanta
a place she got to know during her
decade of marriage to media mogul Ted
Turner she's taken an active role in the
community donating
to create the Jane Fonda Center at Emory
University which focuses on adolescent
reproductive health issues this year
she's come out of movie retirement for a
role opposite Jennifer Lopez as the
difficult mother-in-law in
monster-in-law
if the trailer is any indication I think
a lot of us have probably seen that I
have to say I'm glad I'm happily married
to someone whose mother likes me
in a recent NPR interview Jane said the
most important thing in her life right
now is her grandchildren I'm sorry to
say but for a lot of us it's hard to
imagine Jane Fonda as a grandmother but
she is and she's as proud as any doting
grandparent please join me in welcoming
the world's and the country's
best-selling grandmother Jane Fonda
thank you
thank you very much thank you all so
much for being here I'm honored to have
been asked Kathy thank you for arranging
this Kathy Munk I I have to just mention
a few other people who are out in the
audience
Bobby Mueller's over there Bobby founded
Vietnam Veterans of America and you
mentioned coming home Bobby Bobby was
also largely responsible for the
character that Jon Voight played and
coming home thank you for being here
Bobby thank you and then to people that
are really dear to me I didn't know they
were coming and I'm very very touched
Tim Wirth and Ren Werth are here Tim
Wirth runs Ted Turner's UN Foundation
and has been a huge influence in my life
as has Ren thank you for being here
Susan Blumenthal dr. dr. Susan
Blumenthal who's next to Tim Wirth just
retired as the assistant Surgeon General
of the United States her specialty is
suicide and depression and women and she
helped me with my book because my mother
suffered from depression and and I'm
very grateful to see you Susan thanks
for being here
for the last decade or so I've been
trying to understand and do something
about the ways in which gender
stereotypes handicaps girls ability to
give authoritative voice to their hearts
why so many give them a with themselves
away so lightly
I've also paid close attention to the
often destructive ways in which boys try
to prove their manhood that's why I
wanted Michelle a Zumba to be here
tonight Michelle is the executive
director of an organization that I
founded ten years ago in Georgia the
Georgia campaign for adolescent
pregnancy prevention and I wanted her to
be here to represent the work that we do
together which I'm so proud of Thank You
Michelle for being here Cecile Richards
is someone with whom I have worked to
encourage women to make their voices
heard in the political process too often
women feel that they can leave the issue
of voting matters to their husbands or
feel fatalistic about the possibility of
making a difference and as a result
issues like health care poverty forced
pregnancy childcare and violence aren't
up front and center as they should be
thank you for being here Cecile she is
one great organizer Gloria Steinem was
the first woman who spoke at the
National Press Club in 1971 for which he
was given a tie Gloria Steinem has
inspired me taught me and deeply moved
me even before she was my friend and
when I got to know her she was always
patient with me even when she knew that
on a deep level I didn't get it and now
that I do now that I am able to fully
embrace and understand feminism I am
doubly grateful to her like all true
great leaders she leads generously and
from her heart I love you Gloria thank
you for being here
so as we meet tonight you may be seeing
me through the lens of the media reports
of my life or through my book and I may
be seeing you through my various
experiences with the media I have the
same hopes for tonight as I do for my
book that gave rise to it that we will
be able to see each other as complex
human beings and that we will find each
of us within those complexities lessons
to strengthen our own lives and work so
I'm not going to focus on the parts of
my book that the media have picked up
uniformly the two h's Hanoi and husbands
those are fair game and important but
probably not all that useful to the
lives of the people in this room except
as parables for example there might be
for you as journalists a useful parable
of who decides what's news and what
isn't the famous photograph of me on an
anti-aircraft gun wasn't considered
newsworthy until six months after the
fact when President Nixon decided it
should be just as I have taken the full
responsibility for my lapse of judgment
it might be helpful for the media to
take responsibility for a 35-year
repetition of a partial but not a full
story of the Vietnam War
and I I can't help but feel that that
has contributed to the lack of
understanding of that war in this
country and why the wounds are still so
open reporting both sides might have
discouraged what has come to be called
Swift boating disqualifying the message
by disqualifying the messenger in the
same way reporting the success of the
stated purpose of my trip to Hanoi
exposing by filming the flood and
starved tactics of the u.s. bombing of
the system of dikes on which food and
life depend can I have some water please
bombing that was denied by the Nixon
administration but which stopped a month
after I got back reporting of those
reasons might have encouraged more
activism and brought the war to a halt
earlier perhaps we wouldn't have been as
ready to believe the lies that got us
into Iraq if the American public had
been made aware of the previous
government's lies about the war that
resulted in so many unnecessary deaths
both American and indo-chinese
for instance back in 1968 when the
Johnson administration fabricated the
Tonkin Gulf incident so as to get
Congress to allow him to bomb North
Vietnam and in 1972 right before the
presidential elections when Henry
Kissinger announced that peace was at
hand in order to insure Nixon's
re-election when in fact our South
Vietnamese a line when Van hew had not
agreed or from 1972 until his
resignation in 1974 while he was telling
the American people that he was ending
the war President Nixon Nixon was in
fact escalating it none of this was
prominent in the press and what a
difference it might have made then and
now
as for the focus on husbands it could
provide a lesson about how the news is
gendered would the autobiography of a
male actor who had been married to
famous women be characterized in quite
the same way for that matter what my
fitness videos have been reported in the
same way or instead might they have made
me governor of California
so I'll bypass the two H's and focus on
other ways our lives and politics are
dictated by what I call in my book a
gender grounded narrative I believe the
absence of an understanding of gender
politics is not only allowing them to
continue in silence and thus perpetuate
all violence except that related to
immediate self-defense but it also
causes the media to miss the biggest and
deepest parts of many news stories for
instance there's a reason why the so
called senseless killings in this
country killings and schools or other
public places with no gain for the
killer in fact usually was suicide for
the killer our predominantly male white
middle-class and non poor the proportion
of serial killings that are not
committed by white men is about the same
as the proportion of anorexic who are
not female the perpetrators of mass
murders are not boys and men who are
suffering most in this country on the
contrary it is the group most likely to
be raised to believe they have the right
to dominate and thus to get hooked on
domination and to feel shame when they
can't dominate yet the media misses the
story by asking what's happening to our
children instead of asking what's
happening to our sons but gender
narratives that make men so vulnerable
to shaming so fearful of being seen as
not man enough has affected every part
of our lives including our body politics
and especially issues of war and peace
for example for 30-some years I have
wondered why would five American
administrations Democratic and
Republican knowing according to the
Pentagon Papers that we could not win
militarily in Vietnam
knowing that they would have to keep
escalating the war to avoid losing it
why would they choose to postpone
failure and end the killing regardless
why did they keep going regardless of
how many lives were being lost partly it
was to get elected President Kennedy
told Arthur Schlessinger in November
1961 that if the u.s. ever went into war
in Vietnam quote we would lose as the
French had lost a decade earlier unquote
but Kennedy was afraid the right wing
would defeat him in the next election if
he withdrew but mostly I think Daniel
Ellsberg got it right when he told salon
in 2002 quote my best guess is that
Lyndon Johnson psychologically did not
want to be called weak on communism as
he put it to Doris Kearney being Johnson
he said he would be called an unmanly
man if he got out of Vietnam a weakling
and appeaser
Ellsberg went on many Americans have
died in the last 50 years and maybe 10
times as many Asians because American
politicians feared to be called unmanly
unquote unfortunately there are some so
wedded to the notion of American
omnipotence that they claim the right to
destroy any regimes they don't like they
scoff at the United Nations and consider
it and this is from the New York Times
reflective submission to adhere to
international law in his book war
engendered Joshua Goldstein a professor
of international relations at American
University writes quote as war is
gendered masculine so peace is gendered
feminine thus the manhood of men who
opposed war becomes vulnerable to
shaming unquote we know the names that
are hurled at them that have been hurled
at them only last fall wimps soft
[ __ ] girly men beware of men who use
words that relate pejoratively to female
when describing the other side for them
omnipotent and their own potency seemed
to be joined they'd rather disappear
from public life as Johnson did than be
blamed for premature evacuation and what
are we seeing today bring them on right
are you man enough Bush says to carry my
God's bigger than yours says general
Boykin and this mine's bigger than yours
paradigm and drive for domination has
the entire world tilted in dangerous
imbalance damaging not only individual
men women and children but entire
peoples I love to quote Gloria in one of
her books she said that we need to
change patriarchal institutions if we're
going to stop producing leaders whose
unexamined early lives are then played
out on a national and international
stage we need to define a democratic
manhood less susceptible to shaming
because it's virility is not dependent
on dominance we need to raise sons who
resist the gender narrative and stay
connected to their hearts and not just
their balls
today today reality demands
internationalism multilateralism
humility and compassion Christian values
as well as Buddhist and Jewish and
Islamic and others we talk about values
these are the real values but these
approaches are considered effeminate by
the men who are currently running our
country you know there's a lot of talk
about Christian values but I wonder if
Christ came back today if he'd be
labeled effeminate by these same people
I mean those disciples that hair the
emphasis on forgiveness that's
suspicious identification with peace
women and the pork come on just as there
can be no democracy without feminism
without the self authority of the female
half of the human race there can be no
lessening of violence without the full
humanity of the male half that means
humanizing the masculine role that
normalizes and even demands violence
just as it means rebelling against the
feminine role we all have responsibility
to end this division of humanity into
the leaders and the lead subject and
object victim and victimizer but we
can't end what the media tell us is
normal or inevitable because it's
treated as invisible we all understand
that things are not easy for you I'm
talking to the media with consolidation
of press ownership threats of access to
power loss of access to power pressure
from the top it's hard it's scary but
you are our last hope in the world's now
sole superpower where one party controls
two and a half of the three chambers of
government and is out to get the last
half in court appointments and we're
even Republicans like Senator John
Danforth publicly deplores the takeover
of his party by extremists we need you
to be brave to dig deeper even when it's
hard
I started off talking about voice and
I'll close by asking that you give voice
to and render visible all that has been
in vis
for too long thank you very much
I left lots of time for questions we
have a wide wide variety of questions
I'd like to start with some questions on
the themes of of the speech let's start
with women and politics which women in
politics do you respect the most well I
like all women who have decided to run
for office because whatever party we
belong to we're different
which is good we're gonna bring certain
issues to the fore so I wish there were
more of us you know I'm
my father was a yellow dog Democrats so
I'd you know I he'd strike me dead if
I'm a Democrat but so I you know I'm
closest to the women the feisty women
who are Democrats but I'm just grateful
that women have the guts to move into
the political arena and I admire them a
lot do you think that 2008 could be the
year that a woman is selected either
president or vice president and there is
talk that both parties could nominate a
woman either at the top of the ticket or
as number two I don't know what do you
all think I don't know but you know
something there are women who really are
ventriloquist's for the patriarchy and
there are men of real conscience who are
feminists what matters is heart and
conscience and compassion and empathy
and courage but it would be nice
since we have a lot of reporters in the
audience today do you think that the
press is a patriarchal institution and
are there any any examples that you've
seen over the years Oh men well the fact
is that most media institutions radio
and television and print is run by men
ah PD opinion editors on the newspapers
are mainly men this is across the board
across the country and what that means
is that our voices are women's voices
are not being heard enough and there's
tables of us here who want to try to do
something about it
yes so yes it is patriarchal frankly and
but that doesn't mean that it can't be
changed well speaking of change this is
sort of an advert for the home team here
the Press Club was a place for decades
and decades that discriminated against
women and I'm afraid to say I broke the
streak of two women as president of the
of the Press Club but questions on the
news anchors we've had we have a new
generation of news anchors that's the
way a lot of people still get their news
on network news do you think it's time
and do you expect to see women as the
network news anchors anytime soon
what do you have to say about that
Gloria it could happen
we're holding our breath which means
that it might not be too much longer but
you know we have to end the era of women
as sidekicks now it's too too good not
to ask about a couple of politicians you
mentioned before one is the girlie men
guy he started out very very popular and
he's going through a rough patch right
now what do you think is his political
future is he certainly can't run for
president unless we amend the
constitution but do you think that it
will backfire or do you think that the
routine that he's honed through several
decades in films will hold out for him
I am I know Arnold and I like him but I
I think that the bullying that you do in
movies as a character doesn't work in
politics and his future will depend on
how he is able in the very near future
because he doesn't have that much more
time I think to make up for some of the
problems that have happened how quickly
he can listen to nurses and teachers and
you know all of the the unions and and
the working the work force that are
largely women and the Californians
really respect and admire and need and I
think he's alienated those unions and
those and those service providers and
those women and I think you know I I
hope Maria can can whisper in his ear
Maria should run there were a couple of
media related questions one has to do
with the way in which women are sexually
subjugated in music videos and other
programs targeted to younger generations
I was wondering what you think in the
popular culture of the presentation of
women and the way women or women are
treated in in music music videos and pop
culture music videos fashion magazines I
just made a speech a few weeks to go to
a conference of girls high school girls
in Bozeman Montana and one of the things
that I it wasn't any surprise but I
really heard how how much the the images
of all these really really thin women
have affected these young girls that are
just beginning to develop their identity
and they want to look like the women and
the girls in the in the in the fashion
magazines and I said the women in the
fashion magazines don't look like that
these with these digital cameras now
their bodies are cut and rearranged and
it's all and they were so relieved to
know that these these girls but one of
the things that we're working on in
Georgia is we're trying to inoculate
young people against the influence
the media you know while we're waiting
to change it and take it over there's a
thing called social inoculation it's a
it's a social it's a theory of how to
change behavior
if you politicize the meet with the
media if you can help them on struck tit
so they understand why they they're made
to feel so anxious and why how the these
images are affecting them and how much
it's based on sex and violence it will
help them to be able to stand back
distance themselves from it and and be
and be inoculated so we're we're working
on that but it's it's a critical issue
there are two questions about news
coverage one from reporter how can we be
brave when our bosses are media
conglomerates not interested in
hard-hitting news and someone asked else
asked about the difference between hard
news and soft news on on TV and also in
newspapers and magazines how can we be
brave when our bosses are media
conglomerates not interested in
hard-hitting news risk being fired
I mean step out and be brave and risk
being fired hopefully there will be a
home for you somewhere where you can
where you can speak from your heart as
reporters as the media I mean when you
stay in a job that is betraying your
soul it kills you it kills you I know
because I've done it you said that
you're so happy now working for as an
advocate in an environmental
organization because you can speak from
your heart we should all be speaking
from our heart let the conglomerates
collapse Ted Turner would applaud if he
was here I know that
wouldn't hate him let you know just
speak speak and be brave what do you
what do you think of your media coverage
over the years how much has been fair
how much has been sensationalistic I
mean you talked talked a good deal about
the coverage of the Vietnam War ii-era
but over your entire career you know I
well you know it's been gendered and
it's been sensationalized but I'm not a
complainer I don't when you decide that
you're going to enter the movie business
you have to take what comes with that
and you have to own it I mean I I and
I'm and I'm an organizer and I'm an
activist and so in a large part my
celebrity has helped me with the
activism in my life the thing that hurts
me the most about the coverage over my
life has to do with the Vietnam War
because I know and Bobby Miller and many
of you know that the reason that this is
so rife still that the wound is still so
open is because we do not understand
what that war was about and you know I'm
a lightning rod I own that I take
responsibility for it what makes me sad
though is that is that we can't move on
from there because there's so much
revisionism
and we've allowed it to happen if two
people ask the same question if
President Bush were here tonight and
he's not because he's over at the
Nationals game right now what would you
ask him or tell him what question would
you if you could be in the White House
press corps ask President Bush
I would love to go to a barbecue with
him and just know really and just kind
of like go off in a corner and talk
because I think I think that we'd
probably get along just fine but I would
want to know why why he doesn't read
more why why he doesn't I mean by now I
remember the first trip he took overseas
and when he first came back he was
saying I'm doing I'm paraphrasing
they're mad at us and I'm thinking what
kind of daily briefings is he getting I
wish that he was I would like to take
him to Africa I'd like to take him to
India I'd like to take him to the
third-world countries so he could see
the results on the ground of his
policies I don't think he knows the
women that are dying because of his gag
rules
look I just I don't know what kind of
information he's getting so I guess I
would say why don't you read more and
and and and forget about those handlers
that are all around you you know but go
with your heart I'll never get a chance
to say it though about anyway
they're all going going from there to
some of the bush policies there are a
lot of questions about Iraq and if you
see any parallels between Vietnam and
Iraq and then you talked about Daniel
Ellsberg do you think that we are going
to have Pentagon Papers down the road
talking about what led us into into Iraq
did anybody read John Dean's book worse
than Watergate yeah I wanted him to be
here too but he couldn't I thought it
would be fun that wants a plaintiff and
my lawsuit against the Nixon
administration has now become a friend
well this book was an important book
worse than Watergate and I bring it up
an answer to that question because if he
did a lot of research and I don't know
if there can be a Pentagon Papers of the
Bush administration because they ain't
going to
anything survived they're going to
destroy if there won't be any tapes and
records left behind I don't think I mean
this is such a secretive tight you know
little little group what was the
question
what's that the question oh okay
oh yeah Pentagon Papers that's how I got
to John Dean
well the lies it's so hard when you're
at war to believe that your leaders
could be lying to you I think it's the
election showed that we just it's just
as a people we just it's hard to go
there because if you go there if you
really allow that reality to sink in and
to realize that our leaders have lied to
us
it shakes the foundations of your
identity if this is true then Who am I
and those of us who do read haven't
figured out how to answer that question
then Who am I of course I think then who
you are is a real Patriot and a real
American basically the big the big
similarity because it's a very different
war and I won't go into the reasons now
although I'd love to but is the fact
that we are we relied to it again into
it just as we were in Vietnam that men
are dying needlessly and women
unnecessarily and that I worry as you
all do as we all do that it's becoming a
situation like ok it was a mistake but
now that we're there do you know uh-uh
those of us who remember Vietnam know
how many more lives we can we can lose
because of the fear of premature
evacuation that's why I raised this
issue of gender politics in relation to
war and peace we need leaders who aren't
afraid of saying whoops
cut our losses let's let's get out
he criticized press coverage of Vietnam
War conservatives also criticized the
press coverage of Vietnam War during
Vietnam and said it was responsible for
a loss of public support for the war I
was wondering how you reconcile the two
things was the press coverage overall
pro-war anti-war aping the Nixon and
Johnson administration's or excessively
critical of them let me make one thing
perfectly clear the myth that we lost
the war in Vietnam because of liberal
media and the anti-war movement is an
outright lie it's a lie that quote that
I made from President Kennedy that's
what mattered there was no way that we
could win that war and Kennedy knew it I
was living in France with the people who
themselves were defeated in the war
before ours we could not win
we lost 58,000 American lives and
millions of indo-chinese lives for
nothing and I you know I've never said
this publicly but thank God for Robert
McNamara
some people say too little too late but
how hard it is and what courage to have
been an architect of a war and then to
say it was wrong we were wrong and one
of the reasons that he says we were the
mistake was we never knew who they were
our leaders today are not paying
attention to the fundamental rule of
warfare know thine enemy we didn't know
the Vietnamese and we thought it would
be a cakewalk going into Iraq and we
didn't understand who they were and it
comes from hubris and arrogance the
omnipotence of America nobody's number
one forever not individuals and not
nations sooner or later everybody
crashes and I know I hope we don't crash
in hostile territory but we're certainly
headed that way
one of our guests asks so many people of
my generation opposed the Vietnam War
and agreed with what you did why do you
feel it necessary to now apologize I'm
apologizing for one thing one terrible
mistake that I made when I sat on an
anti-aircraft gun and was photographed I
didn't pose there I just was I didn't
think what I was doing and I sat down
and I was photographed and that is what
I have apologized for I didn't apologize
for going to North Vietnam I proud that
I went I think it helped end the bombing
of the dikes 300 Americans had gone
before me right after me our former
attorney general Ramsey Clark went I'm
proud of that every American that tried
to oppose that war in whatever way they
could are the real Patriots right Bobby
you got it we have two questions about
this with both veterans and John Kerry
wanted to get your analysis of what
impact that had on the last election why
you think the Vietnam can still be so
raw an issue so many years later and of
how the Kerry campaign could have handed
the Republicans Vietnam as an issue that
helped George Bush rather than John
Kerry any any campaign that is based on
lies as the Swift Boat attacks on Kerry
was is despicable it has nothing to do
with values it is valueless I think the
problem was if you so many men
volunteered and went to Vietnam as
Patriots and that count it doesn't
matter that the war was wrong their
reasons for going was right and there
and there
many of them discovered the combat
troops the grunts not this
behind-the-scenes or the pilots but the
guys on the ground discovered that it
was wrong that we weren't there to help
the South Vietnamese and some of them
large numbers of them
had the courage the moral courage to
come back and say it and tell the
American people at a time when Nixon was
lying to us what was the truth about
Vietnam and their voices mattered more
than anyone's because they'd been there
and they'd seen and they're their
truth-telling offered to this nation a
chance of redemption and we blew it and
we blew it I wish that John Kerry had
owned that moral courage that allowed
him to stand up at a time when kill the
messenger was was very active what
courage that took and it is despicable
that's still today people take men like
John Kerry and Max Cleland my former
senator from from Georgia triple amputee
in Vietnam and dare to say that they are
weak on terrorism that they are not
patriotic it is despicable and it is the
contrary of Christian values
during the Vietnam era there were a
large number of actors who are
politically active today it's relatively
few why do you think that is and how can
you or others encourage more people in
entertainment to become more politically
active it's a complicated war now you
know in in Vietnam I became involved in
the anti-war movement eight years into
the war most American people opposed the
war most of Congress opposed the war you
know this were two years into the war in
Iraq nobody supported you know Saddam
Hussein everybody felt he was someone
you know who should go it's complicated
but the voices that are speaking out now
that are the most important are the
military voices on the second
anniversary of the war in Iraq at Fort
Bragg North Carolina in Fayetteville
North Carolina the largest anti-war
demonstration took place ever since I
was there in 1970 this was the five
thousand people and who addressed them
were veterans from Iraq were military
families of fallen soldiers military
families for peace this is important
this is two years into the war and
already the military is saying wait a
minute this is wrong it took eight years
in the Vietnam War for that to happen so
I'm very hopeful and the final political
question before I shift gears to
entertainment a little
have you considered running for public
office yourself
no tasks follow apply have you read my
book actually a few weeks ago Angela
Angelina Jolie was here at this very
podium and her answer was too many
skeletons in the closet
well my not in the closet anyway it
seems a little strange to go from very
serious to entertainment but we have a
lot of questions on it looking back
which of your films do you most enjoy
it's like saying what child do you like
better you know each one has a different
you know barefoot in the park because I
always was in love with Bob Redford as a
special and and it's it's hard for a
comedy to last over the years but that
one really holds up Clute was was was a
turning point for me in many many ways
it was the first film I made when I was
beginning to identify myself as a
feminist although I didn't really
understand what it meant but it was an
important film for me coming home was
the first film that that that told a
story that came from my gut because of
people like Bobby Miller and let's see
on Golden Pond there's a whole chapter
in my book about why that was important
I mean just think about it how blessed
am i to have been able to produce a film
for my father which won him is Oscar
five months before he died and in which
he and I could play roles that's so
paralleled real life I mean it was a it
was a mitzvah it was a great experience
it was great did you ever discuss with
your father the parallels while you were
making the movie or or before he made
the movie the parallels between my
relationship with him in the movie oh no
no we didn't find us don't talk about
things like that well there are some
fonda questions of about kin what does
Peter doing now any new movies for him
and what is Brigitte doing now Grisha
just had a baby and Peter's in Australia
making a movie that's that and for you
what new project can we look forward to
what we just had a meeting today many of
the incredible women in this room to
talk about creating a women's radio
network that's one thing since since
unlike our president you are reflective
do you think you're a good writer and
and what do you think of the response to
the book has has gotten from from
reviews and from readers out there am i
a good writer god that's relative you
know with Gloria sitting here no but I
mean there were many I how do I do this
when I was approaching 60 I thought oh
my god it's the beginning of a third act
and I'm an actress so I know that third
acts are important and it's not a
rehearsal it's like riding without an
eraser I mean it's I got to get it right
and so I thought well in order to do it
right I've got to know what my first and
second acts were all about and in the
process of figuring that out I realized
I had a story to tell that had some
universality in it and I wrote to that
universality I felt that if I was brave
enough not to tell all it's not a
question of telling all to tell that
which needed it to be told in order to
raise the theme up that it would be a
book that the reader would constantly
be putting down because they'd be
thinking about themselves and their own
lives and their own relationships and I
am so grateful and moved that in the
week that it's been out this is the kind
of response that I've been getting back
from men as well as women which has
touched me so deeply this I talk about
the disease to please and the the men
that have told me or communicated with
me that talking about it this way has
changed their lives is just is just it's
pulling me over I'm not only number I'm
gonna brag ok I'm not only number one on
the New York Times best whatever it is
nonfiction I'm the number one seller of
any books fiction or nonfiction I'm the
first book to outsell The Da Vinci Code
and I'm working I'm working it so hard
because it's it's no longer my story I
spent five years writing it and and I
think it's important and that's why I'm
out stumping for it because I think it
can make a difference I really do and
and I love writing I just I love the
process of writing it came real easy
although there were times when I didn't
I knew that I didn't have the experience
you know that a professional writer
would have to try to say what I what I
wanted to say but it's good enough they
talked about the disease to please one
of people in the audience ask if he can
talk about bulimia why do you think so
many us women suffer from eating
disorders and how can this change I
learned from Eve Ensler recently that
anorexia has hit Kenya we're exporting
this this disease you know I I can only
speak from my own experience I think it
happens when girls feel that in order to
be loved they have to be perfect and you
don't notice when you're young but when
you hit adolescence and when womanhood
is beckoning suddenly not being perfect
becomes really important and it usually
attaches itself to your body and so many
girls like me moved
I just move outside of myself I took up
residence next door and and that that
leaves an emptiness that fills with
anxiety most girls junior hot juniors
seniors in high school they talk about
anxiety that they feel and they don't
know they just think it's their problem
and it's not it's this it's this
cultural pressure that says we have to
be we have to be perfect and so you fill
it with you know some people fill it was
shopping they want that second pair of
Manolo Blahniks and then everything will
be okay or you know I mean I met a girl
in Bozeman her mother gave her breast
implants for her 60th 16th birthday
people fill it with different things
alcohol sex gambling and I filled mine
with food and it is epidemic and it's a
it's it's a it's a disease like a lot of
other addictions that's hard to heal
from until you learn to fill that
emptiness with something else and I've
come to call it spirit and it doesn't
have to be religious but it's it's hard
for me to even put words to it but you
know AAA I always wondered why AAA talks
about higher power but I understand now
when you become humble enough and
realize that where you are in the scheme
of things there's a softening that
happens and then that can be filled
filled with your soul your spirit your
being you can then move back inside
yourself and become reom buddy did it
took me 62 years and the reason that I
do the work I do now with Michele is
because I don't want other girls and
boys to have to wait that long
and Richards used to say that Ginger
Rogers did I'm sure she still says it
Ginger Rogers did everything Fred
Astaire did only she did it in high
heels and backwards someone in the
audience says how can girls and women be
equal and free when they're wearing skin
tight halter tops that leave them half
naked to say totter with naked feet on
high heels when the guys are on solid
ground and closed shoes with their
bodies covered in loose comfortable
clothes
see if Lauria were up here she'd have
the most incredible answer to that but
I'm too tired I'll be / I don't know how
to answer that do you you wanted to say
something I don't know I mean I don't
wear high heels anymore cuz I'm too old
but I don't know girls should be able to
wear whatever they want without being
harassed and you know and and and hit
upon and so should men you know it's I
we have to believe that a time will come
when when the balance is restored and we
see each other as whole people and not
how we look and don't expect each other
to be perfect that we just show up for
each other I mean I I'm so sad that I'm
old because now that I know this I well
nevermind
I keep forgetting that this is being
televised you can't test it on dogs okay
I mean you have to it's in relationship
that this comes out and you know I just
maybe I'll have another chance I don't
know but you cannot have a relationship
when you're leaving yourself at the door
and I'm just realizing that it's as it's
almost as true for men as it is for
women and it's so hard if you've been
brought up that way and you've been
brought up to feel as a woman that if
you're not with a man you're not you
don't exist you're not valid then it's
so hard to say okay Here I am Here I am
if you can't appreciate all of me I'd
rather be alone thank you I want to
thank you very much for being with us
tonight
one more question coming but before that
question we actually have dozens more
questions here but we've run out of time
c-span's going away in about three
minutes here but before that happens
no ties today and I want to get Gloria
one of these two it's more useful than a
tie National Press Club mug oh now I
have one and a certificate of
appreciation not only suitable for
framing but actually frames final
question we have since this is a media
audience where do you get your daily
news and information okay I wake up I
look at CNN and then I read the New York
Times cover to cover and then I get in
my car and I listen to NPR
well thank you so much for being with us
today I'd also like to thank everyone in
the audience for coming and National
Quest club's members Melinda Cook Pat
Nelson Joanne booze and Howard Rothman
for putting together today's lunch and
thanks to the National prep dinner
yes dinner sorry I'm not a professional
actor my script is out of date and
that's true although you cannot tell in
here as Eric severide said the world's
largest roll-top desk and final thanks
to the National Press Club library for
all the work they did so that I wouldn't
look too dumb today thanks for coming
we're adjourned Jane Fonda is currently
chair of the Georgia campaign for
adolescent pregnancy prevention which
she founded in 1995 my life so far is
published by Random House on the web at
Random House